you
what in your opinion makes a good leader
or qualities ah yes it's a question that
we've had to deal with quite a bit
looking at some of the leaders we have
had who have sometimes led their
countries into disastrous situations I
think ultimately you want a leader who
is also a servant I mean really the
leader is is a leader because he is a
servant when you look at some of the
greatest leaders Nelson Mandela is
someone who is not in it for his own
aggrandizement he he leads on behalf of
for the sake of that is one and it
almost always is that the great leader
will show just how he is or she is a
leader for the sake of the lead by
suffering a person who is a servant as
well that is that is the other side for
me yes that you you are not one who is
seeking self-glorification who who wants
to feather his nest just look say it at
I mean you can look at Mother Teresa or
area mean Mahatma Gandhi the Dalai Lama
you will see that a great characteristic
is they are doing something yeah
sacrificial in a way for the sake of
those they are serving and suffering
well the title
has been in exile for 50 years Nelson
Mandela was in jail mother Teresa lives
with the poor she lived with the poor
Mahatma Gandhi you could go on much in
Luther King and then the the Grist
leader is someone who is inspiring
inspires his followers her followers
awesome suji I mean she said nothing
very much for eleven years and yet she
remains the only real leader in in in
Burma why that somehow the leader is
encapsulate and and and and somehow
represents the best that is in the app
in the people the escalations of the
people and and and yes it is someone who
can inspire
you